it's time for this week's pet project
amy lee joins us from the nspca
and she's talking about a dog who's
looking for a good home
gator an energetic dog right yes gator's
neat is a boy he's just a big bundle of
energy he's a seven-year-old
american bulldog mix um he's so fun he
wants to play with his tennis ball
actually the tennis ball is actually
going to go home with him because he
wants that in his mouth at all times
like it's kind of a stress ball
but he's so much fun he would be great
with a family that has some energy
kids that are 10 plus i mean he's really
really a fun goofy dog
he'd be best as your only dog but we
really want to find him a loving focus
he deserves it he's such a doll
all right so a family can come in and
spend some time with gator
make sure he gels with everyone and if
they have another pet
and want to see if they gel that they
can bring that pet as well right
with gator particularly we prefer him to
be the only just because he can be a
little bit particular with other dogs
some of our other dogs that we have in
the shelter are fine with other dogs but
we always want to do a meet-and-greet
with those dogs that are okay with other
dogs yeah and our riders counselors our
adoption staff that are
awesome they'll help you through that
whole process and kind of guide you
along to find the best fit for your
family
now gator's a strong dog right so our
little kid's going to be okay around
gator considering he's a strong dog
she is he's 70 pounds he's got a
whiplash tail so that's why we prefer
kids 10 plus
for him makes sense all right yeah you
have so many other animals who are
looking for
a good home there uh how can people
learn more about
what's available absolutely visit our
website nevadaspca.org
and you can check out their little bios
and if you're interested in finding out
more about them give us a call
and we'll help you through that whole
process whether it's a cat or a dog or
even a small animal like a guinea pig or
a bunny
amy as always good stuff and good to see
you thanks for joining us today
here's the website that amy talked about
nevadaspca.org or you can call that
phone number
zero three seven zero two eight seven
three seven seven
two two